sie halten zusammen die die noch da sind
im andalusischen thorax tag für tag
steht silvia reis vor diesem kleinen
supermarkt in spanien leben war immer
ihr traum nun sammelt sie essensspenden
um sie anschließend an jene zu verteilen
die in der korona krise job und
einkommen verloren haben
wir haben angefangen im april
da hatten wir mit 67 familien angefangen
mittlerweile sind wir schon beim 20 ist
tendenz steigend leider
wir haben diesen verein gegründet weil
wir das bedürfnis hatte sie den leuten
ein bisschen unter die arme zu greifen
nachdem wir das erfahren haben dass sehr
viele durch den lockdown finanzielle
nöte geraten sind
die gespendeten lebensmittel liefert
silvia reist an spanische wie an
deutsche familien
seit 25 jahren wohnt und arbeitet nennt
sie zeigen in talks nie hätte sie
gedacht dass sie eines tages nicht mehr
für sich und ihre tochter sorgen kann
mach endreinigung und so ja und es
momentan 2 sowie nicht tourismus was wir
momentan haben bleibt natürlich die
arbeit weg und das geld natürlich dann
auch noch also dann war für dich nicht
mehr vernünftig ernähren kann also das
ist schon krass auch das gesagt
trox costa das dorf der deutschen ein
rentner paradies am mittelmeer gut
140000 deutsche sind in spanien gemeldet
die meisten kommen zum überwintern wegen
des milden klimas
doch die angst sich anzustecken hält sie
in diesem jahr davon ab und so lehrt es
sich zusehens das küstenstädtchen dass
sich über die jahre an seine neuen
bewohner angepasst hat deutsche
geschäfte und produkte deutscher service
ein deutsches ärztezentrum hier arbeitet
carla alonso zwar verzeichnet der kleine
ort kaum mehr als 40 corona fälle
doch die ärztin schaut auf das ganze
land rekordmeldung vergangene woche
12.000 neuinfektionen die zahlen
schnellen in die höhe
wiedermal sowie im märz als zu spät
reagiert wurde
[Musik]
das ist doch nicht so schlimm
stattdessen ist spanien trauriger
spitzenreiter
besonders heftig trifft es abermals
madrid jeder fünfte test fällt positiv
aus und es fehlt immer noch an personal
um die infektionsketten nachzuverfolgen
die korona politik steht massiv in der
kritik
ärzte und pfleger drohen mit einem
langen streik nun rächt sich die frühe
lockerung des lockdown zur sommersaison
quarantäne regeln wurden immer wieder
ignoriert die stadt hat daher neue
lokale absperrungen angekündigt
ich habe keine ahnung wie das sie im
winter sein
alles ändert sich ständig ich vertraue
darauf dass man einen impfstoff finden
wird und die pandemie unter kontrolle
bringt die regierung bestimmt jeden tag
neue maßnahmen die bestimmungen wechseln
von woche zu woche
ich habe keine ahnung wie es weiter
gehen die wirtschaftlichen folgen machen
mir fast mehr angst als das virus selbst
gerade was die kleinen geschäfte und
läden angeht wird es immer schlimmer
inzwischen dürfte hermann perez seinen
legendären club wieder öffnen
doch für den 70-jährigen veranstalter
sind die abstandsregeln zu kompliziert
zu streng
es lohne sich einfach nicht die bühne
wieder zu bespielen
die auflagen sind so hoch dass es für
uns nicht rentabel ist
wir hätten verluste und würde kapital
verlieren
deshalb machen wir nicht auf er vermisst
klarheit seitens der behörden eine
perspektive für sein konzerthaus vor
allem aber vermisst er die künstler und
die gäste abend für abend fanden hier
konzerte statt 35 jahre lang ohne pause
ich bin traurig das schöne an einem
konzerthaus ist doch nicht die show
sondern das publik
die beste show ist nichts wert können
die zuschauer viel
und was ist dein urlaubsort wenn die
touristen fehlen mit strengen hygiene
regeln versucht der bürgermeister den
gästen die angst zu nehmen
box vor den folgen der pandemie zu
beschützen
die pandemie wird in spanien viel
schaden anrichten und ich hoffe das
tarox nicht so sehr in mitleidenschaft
gezogen wird
aber der schlüssel dazu liegt bei den
tausenden von deutschen dass die die
normalerweise hierherkommen es auch
weiterhin tun
doch corona hat das lebensmodell viele
auswanderer verändert still ist es in
ihrer nachbarschaft der
reihenhaussiedlung in der sie seit drei
jahren wohnen
[Musik]
dieses typische spanische freundlichkeit
mit umarmung christian links küsschen
rechts ist natürlich fällt weg zurzeit
ist halt ellbogen begrüßung
hauptsächlich es sind sehr wenig
touristen hier gewesen dieses jahr und
ich denke auch es werden wenig durch ist
bekommen dieses jahr
es ist leer trotz krise trotz corona
hält das auswanderer part two rocks die
treue
sie hoffen dass urlauber rentner und mit
ihnen die jobs an die costa del sol
zurückkehren